you probably heard about McDonald's new
mascot its kinda knew it at least new
here in the United States his name is
happy
but look at Happy this guy's happy that
the scary freak and I've got that's real
when I saw this birth I thought it was
one of those stories that you see
there you go no that can't possibly real
cat that looks scary to me I
happy according to the Gallup press
releases about bringing more fun and
excitement to keep meals including
eating wholesome food like
low but younger great now we can we can
come back at
happy just when you look at Happy the do
you feel happy
what is the emotion that happy brings
out your well
I will say this: in my personal hell
thousand the
characters will be charging toward me
with for eld happy playing on repeat
yeah you know that they had
make that an armed will never be cool
and it will never be healthy they're
trying to give it new thing where they
like
I think the mad with a train appeal to
hipsters recently
I'd be in this this looks like some
graphic designer in college with in
their room in my put together this like
very amateur looking
graphic to me it not it doesn't you know
the symbolize anything that is that cool
impression
whatever right so I want to get to the
cool and fresh thing but first just
on happy himself here's the thing I
don't think
do this I've been happy I've never been
that happened
you never know never been remotely and
happy that Happy Meal
I am and yet there isn't the the
they're replacing all the food they they
giving you like apple wedges
in the Happy Meal and maybe that X
amount of sugar is a put some
over-the-top
I'm baby I i do it doesn't look
like something professor yet looks like
clipart
the heck it looks like something a
comedy show would make
in order to make fine have a
Happy Meal type mass yet is there
something deeply psychological going on
with metallic that they have to do
something that bad it over the top
because it exactly where your point is
which is they're trying to be something
they're not so they care
authentically make something that would
be or I really great anything
the word deep and psychological I cannot
be upset if you think that %uh
both why that I am United trying to give
them the benefit of the doubt here
no I don't think they deserve any
benefits the dow yeah
definitely the doubt given as much as
possible it's crazy that
eyeballs on that thing the back that I
mean look at it
its eyes are permanently pretty little
after having back up there
it's very scary it has an enormous had
at the wedding show itself is very in
writing I feel like I can cuz they have
been there for hours our rate like
they've got tix yeah
treatment rating that the veneer T the
eyes peeled back the skinny this would
be a it's Bruce Jenner
yeah it kinda there's no and I
the elbows like eat happy meals and you
will have no bones in your
are you no bond than just an incredibly
large torso
yeah it's just so this this kind of
gives me positive reinforcement that
people have
caught on to McDonalds cuz when I with
it when I was a kid
we would eat Happy Meals all the time
because that was just what you did in
the eighties he and we have
have we have birthdays parties or their
member the birthday breakfast at
McDonalds would
pancakes yeah good my incredible yeah
in the end it now people are on them and
they have to resort to these very
strange
things and it's almost like someone who
is the age a break rock was like what a
kid like Abu near
give them one use a computer so that's
what it is when we started this by
saying that we all are on to the
the thing that they're doing now so it
has to be over the top the show with
hipsters
everyone everyone's always been their
commercials also would you be going to
McDonalds generally the people I
that bit they're not that happy at all
that directly
okay but they they they just keep
doubling down liked it to push the image
yet I i think i mean you know you never
wanna run into someone
you know and the McDonald it's really
like it not ugg
yeah gathering but not the but iraq
a fast food at all but those commercials
were all those hip good-looking people
like sending fries to the girls out
there that a liar
I'm to iran you know I'm totally gonna
and he's in Frederick
I'm you don't know where is the old
school party around nope
where credit's where murder Hamburglar
yeah like the Hamburglar
yeah I like shooting heroin in a corner
somewhere right now like they've given
up on life
you know you never firming dunno what at
everything so offensive these days the
grimmest I'm sure would offend
Purple People our way at Hamburg
whatever I love to eat at McDonald's all
the time I the shape agreement you know
when I remind people right yet the
Hamburglar in a criminal's
guys do realize that the comment is
gonna say were elitist bastards for
making fun at mcdonnell and they would
be correct their
okay yeah you know i i applaud me downs
reason it am still like put
lettuce and things but now there's like
a great let it now as opposed to like
the iceberg version they used to have
great and they offer a grill a grilled
chicken
right of the photograph for grilled
chicken branding to be pressed into
other cut otherwise perfectly yeah why
don't they just do the honest thing in
just 30 admit what they are cuz I
think it why don't they just double down
on that instead of the lie that somehow
the healthier good pre-war
buy nor happy why don't they get a quick
we know this is fast food like
they're not getting anybody will
honestly be nice I would go to make down
out more often
if there was like just like them
overweight guy I really sad and
depressed I'm given up on life
but a manual me a big mac will my time I
believe yeah
like it you know right yeah I also like
it when you're in the Olympics comes
around
all the Olympians are spotted by
McDonalds anything if those are the only
people who can
eat McDonalds yet because those are the
people who can eat 5,000 calories a day
and still maintain a busy cuz they're
working out all the time that's what you
know I remember the old remember the
Larry Bird the Michael Jordan koranic
about what that were in everything that
there are they like these guys would
never eat McDonalds during the playoffs
because it's not like the libyans where
they have to keep being just for
whatever
right I like their I'll take the money
from now
up